let's talk about the transition from
President Obama to president-elect
Donald Trump it was all fun and games at
the beginning of mutual praise Donald
Trump went to the White House in met
President Obama the Oval Office and uh
Trump came out saying Obama's a good man
I like some Obamacare provisions very
much it all seemed like a very friendly
transition and the optics sort of word
that but it's actually gotten very ugly
right now in diplomatic terms think
about it for a second President Obama
sanctions Russia for their alleged
involvement in hacking the election as i
said earlier in the show Trump tweets
that Vladimir Putin is actually really
smart for how he handled what President
Obama did huh not exactly the signs of a
peaceful transition of power where we
have two leaders current and future on
the same page with the u.s. relationship
to foreign powers Trump says he wants
more drilling more fossil fuels he hires
Rex Tillerson Exxon CEO to be Secretary
of State and then President Obama bands
oil drilling off the Atlantic coast and
in the Arctic that's a direct response
pad to what Donald Trump has been saying
he will do yeah I mean it's clear that
these people don't like each other and I
think that goes back to when Donald
Trump was questioning the citizenship of
Barack Obama and later when Obama
ridiculed Trump at the White House
Correspondents Dinner yeah they've been
able to put on this veneer that they're
you know getting along being cordial but
I think that'll fade away if you look at
what President Obama is signing into law
you see that there is nothing friendly
about this another example Trump select
this outrageous ambassador to Israel
David Friedman I talked about this in
the last week before we went on break
David Friedman is in the minority of the
minority that wants more settlements in
Israel one of the biggest impediments to
peace in Israel and President Obama has
since criticized Israeli settlements
this is a direct response to Donald
Trump since election day President Obama
has named a hundred and three different
people to a variety of key commissions
and jobs including the Council on
disability Amtrak's board of directors
etc all of these positions have
influenced
and President Obama has also freed more
nonviolent drug offenders Trump remember
campaigned on law order jailing people
getting tough etcetera is this this I
don't know how else to say it but the
only way you can think this is a
friendly transition is if you just
remember this picture that were showing
with the handshake and ignore the
actions that have been taken there's
nothing friendly about it yet
unfortunately a lot of the actions that
Obama's taking now are gonna be subject
to being overturned when Trump steaks
office so I mean he'll try his best to
to keep some of his changes into law
yeah but a lot of them will be in the
chopping block it it depends what we're
talking about i mean the the obama
administration is working as carefully
as it can to do as much as it can in a
way that can't be overturned so like the
Arctic drilling ban for example yes
president Trump could attempt to
overturn it but it would likely be tied
up in courts for years so if I McCord's
another one it would take four years to
get out of that exactly so uh and and
Trump is noticing this he got on Twitter
he said disregard the many inflammatory
President Obama statements and
roadblocks thought it was going to be a
smooth transition not uh and as Pat
mentioned some of the actions could be
reversed summer stronger legally this is
sort of part of for me the too little
too late of Obama that we've talked
about uh basic income make sense
President Obama saying in the last
couple of weeks hey that's something you
might have wanted to say in 2009 we'd
should be legal and regulated like
tobacco or alcohol I get it not
politically uh safe to do that maybe in
2009 but did you have to wait until
December of 2016 to say that I would
argue President Obama could have could
have said something more forceful about
that before is this for you pat part of
the too little too late or are you more
in the camp of he couldn't have done a
lot of these things earlier on I mean I
think he was thinking strategically but
it is too little too late i think he
would have gotten enough support behind
you know coming out in favor of gay
marriage before it was popular coming
out in favor of legalization of
marijuana anyone been able to get much
done with it but you know now we see he
has a republican except successor it's
gonna be too little too late i believe
and i think many in our audience agree
President Obama has always been in favor
of gay marriage and has always been in
favor of the legalization of marijuana
and that you could interpret that two
ways pathway which is it was strategic
there was no political advantage saying
that at the time or he should have just
told us what he really believe that's
what that's what the really strong
politician would have done different
views I'm open to hearing from the
audience what you think a facebook.com
slash david pakman show i will be
resuming my facebook livestream soon now
that we are back from vacation the one
place to check it out facebook.com slash
david pakman show thanks for watching
this video before you watch the next one
remember we're raising money to expand
the david pakman show big league as well
as expand progressive activism go to
david pakman.com slash donate donations
of any size are much appreciated